the government doesn't need to be
tracking children
I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Michael Donnelly he's
with the home school Legal Defense
Association and he is representing in a
case that involves a German couple that
is fleeing Germany asking for asylum in
the United States because Germany does
not let them homeschool their five
children Mike thanks for talking to us
tell us kind of as a starting point the
brief facts which are not in dispute of
the rola key case well the family well
Mikey family are from Germany they're
from baden-württemberg a state in
southern Germany where they were living
and sent their children to public school
they decided that that was not the place
where they wanted their children to
continue to learn for variety of reasons
and this part of the reason was is that
they felt that the the school was
putting forth that role models they are
Christian they are Christian family and
they were concerned with the values that
were being taught in the school they
felt that that was conflicting with the
values that they wanted to teach their
children so they wanted to pull their
kids out of the school but Germany
strangely or maybe not so strangely
that's not a la homeschooling correct
that's correct there have been a number
of Supreme Court cases in Germany where
the the German Constitutional Court has
said that it's all right for the states
and Germany to ban home education
because the public has an interest in
counteracting or stamping out parallel
societies and integrating minorities
into the mainstream those are the words
they use right and talk a little bit
about this because there's been some in
some of the discussions about the case
there has been a kind of feeling that
this is a Nazi or a law that you know
the Nazis wanted to control people they
wanted to control kids through the
education system and it actually goes
back further than that in Germany that's
right but you know where where is that
fear now I mean after the words that
they don't want the home schoolers to be
teaching their kids Nazism or something
like that but where does the fear come
from in Germany well when you talk about
this being a Nazi era law which is what
judge Berman who granted the ROE mikey's
Asylum back in 2010 used those words yes
he granted them asylum in the US and
2010
when you look back at the education laws
in Germany you see that in 1938 Hitler's
Reich and it wasn't just Hitler was the
whole Parliament in Germany passed a law
that nationalized the education system
in Germany and criminalized parents who
did not send their children to the state
schools and post World War two they
never put back in the exceptions that
existed that would have permitted
parents to have private tutorial
exceptions or to homeschool their
children and so when you talk about it
being a Nazi law that's what people mean
that's what the judge meant now so the
Romans they left Germany because they
were they were actually afraid that they
could lose custody of their children
they come to the United States and then
in an early court ruling they were
actually granted asylum as people who
were fleeing you know a regime that
would punish them or persecute them for
their beliefs where does that stand now
well they were awarded asylum by judge
Berman in 2010 for two reasons one
because judge Berman found that the
German application of their school law
was frustrating though ramai Keys
religious convictions and secondly that
home schoolers were a particular social
group that the Romans were part of and
that the German government was
oppressing or persecuting them because
of that and those are two elements
within the asylum act that you can
qualify for a sign but that's not where
the case stands right now
No so post-victory in 2010 the Obama
administration appealed that victory to
the Board of Immigration Appeals and in
their arguments they actually said that
homeschooling wasn't a fundamental right
and it shouldn't be protected and that
home schoolers were not a particular
social group the Board of Immigration
Appeals agreed with the government
overturn judge Berman's decision and we
have now appealed on behalf of the
family to the Sixth Circuit Court of
Appeals what's your main case to say you
know this because this is you know
there's an interesting kind of argument
about homeschooling and whether or not a
state should be a you know whether or
not a state should allow people
homeschooling in the u.s. generally
speaking you know we're allowed to do
that but then how does that play into a
kind of immigration refugee asylum well
homeschooling is legal in all 50 states
in America and
only has been for the last 30 years you
know prior to that people in America
home school is in America were actually
experiencing the same kind of oppression
that these these folks are fleeing so
let's before we move on to the German
issue what what flipped because this
reminds me of you know little rascals
episodes or our gang comedies you would
always see the truant officer coming
around the kids rate hiding out her so
how did homeschooling become legal well
was a lot of work on a lot of part of a
lot of people going to their state
legislatures filing court cases our
association was involved in a lot of
those court cases we've been around for
almost 30 years it was a popular
uprising if you will there were tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people getting involved and they said we
want to do this we want to have this
choice the laws don't recognize for it
in some states in other word states that
it was recognized in and so they went to
the legislatures they filed court cases
the number of famous court cases and
over the last thirty years has now
become legal in America and you go back
to 1925 Pierce V Society of sisters a
very famous Supreme Court case that said
that parents have a fundamental right
under the United States Federal
Constitution to direct the education and
upbringing of their children that was in
the context of an Oregon law that was
passed actually by initiative by the
voters in Oregon saying no no private
schools in Oregon you have to send your
children to public schools only really
based supported by the Ku Klux Klan and
an anti-catholic animus at that time
that's what was going on and the Federal
Supreme Court the United States Supreme
Court said no can't do that
parents have a fundamental right okay to
bring it to the ramai key choice you
know why you know if they were Americans
certainly they would have the right to
home-school their kids why should we
allow them to come as refugees well the
asylum Act allows people to Clotho for
asylum if they're in the United States
the mikey's came here they got here if
they're persecuted or have a
well-founded fear of being persecuted on
the basis of five protected classes
particularly social loop the religion
national origin their race and political
opinion okay we argued that their
religious beliefs and they're put in
there members of a particular social
group in Germany home schoolers are
repressed there are stories and cases
scores of cases of families fleeing the
country going to other countries they're
fine tens of thousands of dollars their
children are taken away another Supreme
Court case in Germany
the second one actually said that
homeschooling is an abuse of parental
rights this is a frightening thing to be
coming from the German high courts the
country with a concerning history now
let me just say this Germany is a free
country it's a democratic country it's
an ally of the United States it's a in
many ways a very good country but this
is one area where I think people have a
reason to be concerned when you're
trying to you know prevent people from
teaching their children what they want
to teach them that's very concerning so
when will the case be decided and what
are what kind of odds are you given a
you know grand you're an interested
party so we know you're gonna win easily
beautifully well actually well we hope
so yeah but when when will we find out
what well or mm-hmm oral arguments are
set for April 23rd in a Sixth Circuit
Court in Cincinnati so we'll be arguing
then the Sixth Circuit could take up to
a year or more you know my keys do in
the meantime did they get bounced from
the country are they allowed to stay
here they are staying here they're
staying here and you know the Obama
administration has given a directive to
the immigrations enforcement people not
to deport people who don't have a
criminal record
apparently so we don't think there's any
real risk of them being deported okay I
tell us a little bit more where people
can learn about the home school Legal
Defense Association we have a website HS
Lda org it's a rich resource for people
who are interested in this case or
interested in home school and our
educational freedom what are the other
issues I mean homeschooling on the
growing spectrum or the increasingly
populated spectrum wide spectrum of
school choice is you know out there on
one side you know what are the big
issues that face American home schoolers
these days because it is legal it is you
know what what are the main concerns
well I think the main concerns that we
have is that the state levels there's
continuing efforts to rein in curtail
control you know registration
requirements state imposed testing
requirements I mean in Connecticut for
example there the legislature there is
trying to pass a law that require
homeschooled children to be subjected to
behavioral health assessments by the
government how does that sound that
sounds a little bit of
if you ask me I mean what it's not the
government's place to be investigating
the children's psychological profile who
are home-schooled now this law would
also apply to public school children as
well it's not the place of the
government to be doing that either in my
opinion so those those are the kinds of
things that are out there there are
groups that want to control people at
what point would it be would you save as
a member of the homeschooling community
that it that the state does have a right
to take a kid out of a homeschooling
situation can you you know is is there a
tripwire that you would say is
legitimate well you know we understand
that there is a role for the government
to play and if a child is being abused
or neglected then you know seriously
abuse and neglect there's a place for
the government to step in and protect
that innocent child you know by and
large homes parents who homeschool their
children are not the kind of people who
are gonna abuse and neglect their
children there have been cases very few
cases I would add just a handful of
cases over the years where people have
said well look at that for example the
Benita Jack's case in DC where this
mother ostensibly took her children out
of school to home-school them and they
actually she actually murdered four of
her children and you know that's not a
homeschooling parent and in that case
the social authorities were actually
involved so you know you don't see that
really in a situation where parents are
really homeschooling their children I
mean you know what is the level that the
state should be tracking kids just to
make sure that they are not disappearing
whatever if they're taken out of public
schools or or you know census yeah well
our view is that the government doesn't
need to be tracking children parents are
responsible for their children the
government doesn't need to intervene
unless there's evidence to indicate that
there's something going wrong so you
know in America there are ten or eleven
states that require absolutely no
contact between a home schooling family
and the government in other states it's
a very in about 14 or 15 States you just
simply file a notice either one-time
notice or an annual notice letting them
know hey we're doing this yeah we think
that's okay
in the other states some of them impose
testing requirements you know these have
been found to be reasonable regulations
that have been upheld by some courts in
some cases they haven't been tested I
mean the Pearce case and you know saying
that the child is not the mere creature
of the state also said that the state
can reasonably regulate and establish
minimum standards so you know
constitutionally in from a legal
perspective certainly the the government
has a role our view is it doesn't have
to exercise that role I think you can
trust parents and I think what the
homeschool experience in America has
demonstrated is that you know parents
who are really are home school and their
children are doing a really good job
final question you homeschooled your own
children what would you do what would
you say to them if they come to you and
say dad I really want to go to school I
want to go to a traditional public
school assigned by residents would you
try and talk them out of it or would you
recognize that you had failed as a
teacher I probably do both but you know
I tell you what I would you know if my
children and they haven't done and I
have a 15 down to two I've got seven
children and I think they understand the
freedom that homeschooling allows them
they have some friends and church and
things that they that go to public
school they understand what the public
schools about I don't hide the public
schools from them I talk to them about
the benefits that they have they don't
have to get up at 6:00 in the morning to
get on a bus they they can pursue their
interests they can spend the cup mount
of time that they want to spend on
things that they're interested in well
your children go to college you know if
that's where they feel lead if that's
you know I'm not going to push them to
go to college if they don't really feel
like that's where they should go I I
think there is a place for college I
think you know today in the educational
environment of our nation as it is
developing there are so many options for
children today both high school and
college where they don't really need to
go anywhere now there's nothing wrong
with going to a four-year
brick-and-mortar school either high
school or college but you don't have to
do that and there are many children who
don't you know in a home school
environment for example my children I
have a 14 year old who's taking an AP
class online my 15 year old took one
last year passed the AP exam he's
already gotten college credit this is
not a typical this is typical with home
schools and I think what you see with
the homeschooling movement is really on
the cutting edge of pushing kind of
technology and instructional methodology
and I think that's where we're going as
a country and it's exciting to see that
that
is you know the personalization and the
kind of deinstitutionalization of
education is fascinating and it seems if
anything I mean it's new now but it's a
return to very old practices so we'll
leave it there Mike Donnelly he's with
the home school Legal Defense
Association we'll also follow up on the
Roma key case so thanks very much for
talking to reason TV Thank You Nick for
reason TV I'm Nicholas